à une trentaine de kilomètres de
périgueux en plein coeur de la dordogne
quelques arpents de pâturage entourent
d'une vieille ferme
c'est dans ce décor quelque peu
bucolique au vallonnements infinie un
décor apaisant par le calme qu'il
suggère qu'octave retrouvera brigitte
qu'elle octave qu'elle brigitte vous ne
serez pas leurs noms mais sachez qu'ils
sont les héros romantique d'une
dramatique que claude santelli réalise
pour la première chaîne de télévision
d'après la confession d'un enfant du
siècle d'alfred de musset les enfants du
siècle d'abord c'est très clair c'est la
confession d'un enfant du siècle vous
soumets ya ce deuxième chapitre qui est
restée célèbre qui est peut-être le seul
chapitre connu du livre où il dit ce
qu'étaient ces enfants quiet dans les
parents avaient connu la gloire au temps
des guerres de l' empire et qu' une est
dans un monde de morne vie de stupide et
uniquement pencher sur la richesse et le
profit qui s'ennuie profondément et qui
trouve une espèce d'évasion dans le
désespoir dans cette attaque et un
regard de tous mais visiblement tout
comme al fath de musset octave est un
libertin qui croit pouvoir trouver le
bonheur dans l'amour
oak park ces sommes ce qu'on pensait que
la vie de musset non non je pense pas je
pense qu'il s'est servi de détail
autobiographique c'est à dire sur tout
son aventure avec george sand et la
deuxième partie de la profession et qu'à
l'intérieur lui a mis une certaine
partie de choses qui veut certainement
arriver après ses aventures avec georges
son lait tous les personnages sont
décalés à tel point que george sand
était très effrayés quand elle a appris
qu'on écrivait la confession et elle
croyait que ça allait être totalement
incendiaire qui a traîné plus bactéries
tout et c'est à derrick pas du tout la
manif il en a fait la femme sublime
magnifique aimante aimable et où elle a
été finalement assez désappointé parce
que c'était une sorte de vengeance assez
subtil à mener marie christine barrault
c'est brigitte le personnage féminin
essentiel de ce drame romantique
magnifique que j'aime énormément parce
que c'est un round de foot parleront de
femmes très près n'est pas l'immigré
danse dans la jura le mur si on peut
dire ça disons d'une femme de 30 ans qui
vit sa propre fiche qui est maîtresse de
son destin
il ya beaucoup de gens qui courent je
dis je tourne la confession d'un enfant
du siècle me dit ah oui vous faites
george thorne en réalité d'abord suez
environnement s'est pas du tout journaux
sand et en plus alors le fait que klaus
intérim est choisie moi je vais
absolument rien à voir avec george sand
en a absolument jamais pensé à george
sand en tournant le batteur confession 1
5 12 premières dépouilles sont les
larmes dans vos yeux d'être capable de
crier mais autre le jour vous souvenir
et ça les défauts et les qualités d'une
oeuvre de jeunesse c'est à dire qu'à la
fois il ya la plénitude et la force de
ce qu'un grand amour à cet âge-là peut
vous apporter un grand amour trahi
surtout la force de désespoir et d'amour
mais en même temps c'est un lit qui est
écrit très vite et par un jeune homme
qui écrit keith votre soin que confuse
un peu littéraire peu verbeuse voilà
alors je crois que c'est un livre qui
rebute un peu les électeurs depuis
toujours parce que au-delà de ces
énormes discours d'octave qui
s'interroge d'interrogent dieu qui
interroge sa maîtresse qui interroge son
âme qui dérange le viable il y a des
sentiments tellement fort tellement vrai
et tellement moderne qu'il faut
retrouver tout cela quelquefois un peu
derrière le rideau des mots c'est ce que
j'ai essayé de faire dans l'adaptation
donc on monte d'un cran et on se remonte
et physique de l'esc lévis montée d'un
grand singe est renoncent à monter
prenons le fait que gérard démarre pas
eu foule tout le banc guy vous adhérer
totalement est ce que pense alfred de
musset des femmes ne l'avons pas du tout
absolument pas pas du tout je pense que
c'est très c'est red hat et dans le
temps et certainement des gens qui
pensent encore comme ça mais je pense
que c'est très datée dans le temps ce
qu'il ya c'est une vision du monde tout
à fait mise au gym
la femme se suivent et est fantastique
ce sera plus réputés pouvant câble il ya
véritablement pas de demies lieu entre
les deux le classicisme c'est la santé
le romantisme c'est la maladie mais je
trouve qu'en ce qui concerne la
confession suis très exagéré que vous
traitez votre âme comme les moines qui
flagelle le record vous ne pouvez pas
vivre sans coeur sans tête et on a
toujours un petit peu peur devant le
romantisme ne peut pas du ridicule on a
un petit peu peur d'aller très loin on a
un petit peu peur de certains cris de
certains mots de certaines violences de
certains et sentiments excessif extrême
il faut surtout pas avoir peur donc le
disons que l'essentiel de mon travail
consiste moi quand je me lève le matin à
retrouver ce mélange d'ingénuité de
désespoir de patients de chaleur de ces
jeunes gens qui sont à la fois chaque
instant raid aimé à la folie est prêt à
se suicider dans l'instant même c'est
une histoire folle et il faut être un
peu fou tous les jours pour retrouver ce
ton là
vous ne la connaissez pas
cl
tetris
enregistrer dès maintenant c'est riche
après balzac victor hugo alexandre dumas
george thorne alfred de musset avec sa
confession d'un enfant du siècle entre
dans le répertoire de la télévision et
autres en a une prédilection pour les
grands auteurs classiques et claude
santelli n'en est pas à son coup d'essai
marie christine barrault non plus
d'ailleurs que la télévision puisse
beaucoup dans la littérature pour faire
des films et que c'est finalement un
petit peu le rôle de la télévision je
trouve que ça a permis ça permet à des
tas de gens de découvrir des auteurs que
tâter aurait pas l'occasion de lire je
trouve c'est une très bonne chose on le
fait plus au cinéma on l'a fait au début
cinéma
sauf que maintenant c'est plus le rôle
du cinéma je veux dire c'est beaucoup
plus difficile de faire une adaptation
d'un roman obligé pour la création du
genre dramatique alors je pense que la
télévision ça sert à ça je veux bien ça
sert véritablement à faire des choses
originales comme ça qu'elle soit réussie
ou ratée
j'en sais rien je crois que ça prendra
certainement beaucoup de choses au
public qui avait rang sur une époque
très particulière finalement les gens ne
connaissent pas beaucoup
tout à l'heure vous les faire cela là où
l'équipe n'a je vous impose rien à voir
je place mon autre ali voilà j'ai alors
j'ai mis pour garder leurs manches
alors lorsque le problème est réglé
votre direction de rigueur plutôt la
water la confession 3 1 53e
si midi
octave va donc retrouver brigitte au
pied de la maison où ils se sont vu la
première fois si vous voulez vraiment
connaître toute leur histoire
n'oubliez pas d'ouvrir votre poste
pendant les fêtes de noël et de regarder
la première chaîne de télévision mais
pour l'heure les sons octave et brigitte
seule une minute
tu es mon cou
les chercher il faudrait que j'avais
trio
telenet
tu veux te venger d'elle
ce n'est pas tout
tu oublies sûr que tu as